I don't know who this guy is I vaguely
remember he's some kind of lib woke
Pastor or something we may have covered
before but because Professor Jacob and
Mr Davies didn't get me any interesting
guests today
we're just gonna have to listen to this
guy again uh take it away watching
Conservative Christian responses to the
Congressional testimony about UFOs has
been ridiculous this is the kind of
stuff I've seen the most conservative
Christians saying that aliens are demons
and if aliens turn out to exist it's
just demons pretending to be aliens to
deceive humans throughout history every
time religious people face new knowledge
their first response tends to be to
demonize it to literally say it's of
Satan of the devil and 99.9 of the time
they're wrong just because so the first
part aliens are are just demons for Libs
that's obviously true and he says here's
this claim when religious people
encounter new information new knowledge
they demonize it I would ask him because
this is the sort of thing that seems
true because we're taught a bunch of
lies about history about especially
about the Middle Ages and about the
history of Christianity and especially
about the Catholic church so we're
taught all sorts of lies and people who
have never cracked open the spine of the
history books certainly not in the
theology book and who almost certainly
do not practice a religion consciously
they just believe these things because
they were taught it in seventh grade in
some liberal School in Massachusetts or
something so I guess I would ask him
what would be an example of the kind of
new knowledge that was demonized is I'll
give you an example of the sort of
things I think he's talking about he's
probably talking about certain heresies
that have cropped up throughout history
all kinds of heresies christological
heresies heresies about human nature
about the creation about the Bible all
sorts of things martianism objectionism
various forms of gnosticism and they'll
say Well when those views I don't know
jamesonism when when these new bits of
information came up the religious
authorities demonized them and even
persecuted the adherence were those new
forms of knowledge were they did they
turn out to be true or not
do you do you even know you can even
give an example of what those nude
pieces of knowledge are probably not
and when you do look into them when you
look into all of the heresies that I've
just mentioned they're all Preposterous
and some of them threaten to destroy
civilization if not all of them and the
the thing about history that is really
Charming is despite what we're told that
by the progressives which is that
everything in the past was bad and
everything the presence of Crisis and
everything in the future is going to be
really great if we give the progressives
the power turns out the past wasn't
just universally bad it turns out
that there were ups and downs in terms
of goodness and Badness and flourishing
and Decay and believe it or not the
moment that we're living in right now
probably is not the greatest moment in
all of human history ever
other than in some kind of subjective
way because we have the privilege of
living at this moment if you compare
these things objectively the Liberals
always say we now have more cheap crap
from China so actually it's the greatest
time ever to live but you think well
okay we don't have families and people
are killing themselves and no one has
babies anymore
borders around our civilization and we
don't believe in anything so I don't you
know that maybe it's true we have a lot
of cheap crap from China and that's good
but I'd rather go to a dentist
in in 2012 than in 1220 okay but maybe
there are some other things that
recommend the year 1220 but they never
get specific and when you when you do
get specific in history you recognize
our forebearers especially in the church
and especially the great Statesman of
History
when they made these difficult decisions
to reject certain new ideas or even to
clamp down a little bit and protect
civilization
they were usually right keep going just
because you don't understand something
just because you haven't experienced
something doesn't mean that it's demonic
Jesus told his disciples sure but just
because you haven't experienced
something doesn't mean it's real or good
either that's that both of those gut
reactions are errors and one is the
error that he is I think making a
caricature of uh conservatives as
believing and the other is the error
that the Liberals actually believe which
is oh something's new cool it's great
because we know that all the stuff that
that is current and in the past is bad
and things that are new are just
necessarily good so let's all go to the
bacchanal let's go go to some weird orgy
and learn some new thing from some quack
professors I mean like that no neither
of those things are true to figure out
what's true we need to use our reason
which involves empirical observation and
reasoning through induction and also
deductive reasoning and and
philosophical deliberation and intuitive
reasoning and so I scientific inquiry
and all sorts of things to come to
conclusions like probably the little
green men aren't real they're not really
aliens the fact that virtually
statistically all UFO sightings
have been in the United States or at
least the United States and Europe the
fact that the we don't have any solid
evidence of it the fact that the
so-called whistleblowers Who come out
are always talking about their friends
cousins Brothers sister-in-law's nephew
who happen to see a blurry object but
oopsie couldn't get a photograph or a
videotape of it maybe tells you that the
UFOs are kind of similar to Bigfoot in
that they might just be hallucinations
they might be similar to a lot of other
government misdirection over the years
might just be a cover-up for some
weapons programs that we have or perhaps
don't even have and we're just bluffing
to our enemies or perhaps they might be
what everyone for all of human history
has known exists other than our stupid
secular civilization right now which is
they might be spiritual rather than
corporeal keep going just be open to
learn new things he said he was sending
the spirit to continually lead them and
teach them truth Christians should be
open-minded we should be willing to
learn
stop him from speaking this is really
sacrilegious and and blasphemous really
Blasphemous because what he's saying
here he's lying about what the scripture
says and he's saying that in the gospel
Christ uh says that he's going to send
Spirits down
to but no he says he'll send the Holy
Spirit the third person of the Blessed
Trinity and so this guy is by the way
the unforgivable sin is blaspheming the
holy spirit I'm not saying that's
exactly what he's doing here but he's
engaging in very sacrilegious talk by
saying that actually the little green
men that's really the Holy Spirit or
something like that which reveals a
profound ignorance
at best at that's the best thing I could
say about it maybe uh maybe a culpable
willful kind of ignorance uh but more
than that just an absolute perversion
that could lead people astray if it
weren't so Preposterous keep going to
learn and we should be willing to have
our minds blown at the bigness and the
creativity of our God
yeah man
you know we've just gotta open our minds
so much man that our brains fall out you
know theology is not just let's get
crazy man let's just believe any stupid
thing that someone says theology is
Faith seeking understanding it's
actually the opposite of what that guy's
saying theology is applying logic and
reason and rigor to our intuitions and
observations Fantastical as they may be
I'm not suggesting that our intuitions
and our our observations even can't be
Fantastical but then it is incumbent
Upon Us lest we fall into Superstition
and occultism it is incumbent upon us to
apply reason and rigor and logic to it
[Music]
foreign